la question qui se pose c'est kaz unités
les facteurs favorisant l'émergence de
l'épidémie qui n'est pas un agresseur
extérieur et qu'il y aussi à la manière
à nos modes de vie et la manière dont
nous avons altérer notre kyoto je crois
que c'est un point très important sur
lequel nous reviendrons
la question qui se pose c'est qu'est ce
qui a conduit à une telle impréparation
qu'effectivement les pays et les
citoyens ont vécu un traumatisme un
traumatisme chez un plan
psychopathologique c'est pas l'intensité
du choc
c'est l'état de sidération produit par
un chant quel qu'il soit
en fonction de l'état d'un je crois si
vous voulez que c'est cela aussi que
nous devons poser comme question gelé
semble que le titre est malheureusement
tout à l'heure mais il s'agit de
mobiliser des citoyens
il s'agit de ne pas tomber dans un
individualiste de masse où effectivement
la privation que comporte un confinement
recours au feu peut être vécu comme les
altérations d'une liberté individuelle
c'est pas de problème si nous décidons
collectivement évidemment de respecter
non pas la distance sociale gérée vite
tout de suite quand edouard philippe a
parlé de distance sociale s'agit d'une
distance physique qui nécessite
justement l'accroissement de dans une
relation sociale
c'est ce qui est important dans ma
région si vous voulez les élus locaux
sont prêts à mettre la main à la pâte
s'ils ont déjà convoqué si vous voulez
les pompiers etc
en gros il y aurait la possibilité
régionalement d'avoir un appui pour
pouvoir justement vacciner parce que
c'est ça la solution
si nous devons faire un confinement si
pour en faire quelque chose c'est pas
simplement pour faire une pause en
restant à faire enfermer dans sa chambre
c'est pour en profiter pour
effectivement vaccinés vacciner vacciner
encore et nous sommes dans une véritable
course de vitesse que les uns facture
ils connaissent bien ils peuvent parler
beaucoup mieux que moi qui s'appelle là
l'hypothèse de la reine rouge ou en gros
le virus se transforme en même temps que
nous nous transformons en prenant des
mesures et il faut accélérer
or je vous donne accès les romains
[Musique]